okay cool
uh hey guys good to see you all uh
welcome to uh css conf
eu 2014 um so good to see you guys uh
you can see this is the uh
if anyone who's here uh one more time
who's here last year
nice good showing um so yeah it's just
like
carrying on tradition um so i'm gonna
start just by saying
uh they have a whole new um design
oh geez i'm sorry that's that's embarra
i don't css is not really my my forte
i'm just gonna have to go into
developer tools go to the z
index and two
and refresh the browser yes there it is
welcome to css configu
z z-index is two um
you might be familiar uh with this
conference from such other conferences
as css conf which took place for the
first time
uh last year also uh in america uh
and then it just spun off into css
comppu
uh and now it's actually become an even
bigger thing now we have uh cs conf uh
au in australia are you guys here let's
see if you guys
i say they are over there um so yeah
it's just like jsconf
has become now it's like all over the
world cs conf is too which is really
neat
uh although i gotta admit i hate to call
you guys out but it's
i don't think it's that hard to start a
css comp au i mean basically all you
have to do is just take
css comp eu and then
apply a css transform rotating 180
degrees turn the e around
it's pretty easy so whatever guys um and
who knows where it's going to go from
here you know maybe
right next door in france we'll have
brie s conf
and maybe i don't know i'll inspire like
switzerland to have like
paul cleo s conf and then maybe italy
would have its italy
i don't know i don't know but anyway
there's a there's a it's turning into
like a thing that happens all over the
place which is really really cool but
we're not talking about that we're
talking about here back in berlin
uh on the river spray uh so maybe it's
like spree ss conf
um this river uh so we've moved if you
were here last year we were
up i guess in prince louderberg on
invenstrassa in a beautiful old building
and now we're down here we're uh towards
a south uh part of town
um right on this beautiful river which
you can actually see
um it's right there um it's really easy
to find if you guys already know css
uh because the river you just gotta find
uh use a selector you find it's a
spandau
uh and it's between that and the the
berlin so
uh it's pretty pretty easy to find uh
and it's here in this
uh beautiful uh venue uh the radio
system
i believe if i'm pronouncing that
correctly um
it used to be in old waterworks uh which
is uh probably very useful for those of
you interested in
fluid layouts um but otherwise
i don't know much about the venue
otherwise other than that it's beautiful
i think i'm pretty sure radio system
is uh i checked the map and it checks
out that it's actually i think it's a
a border radius of five so um
beautiful venue right here in the middle
of berlin uh
literally the middle of berlin it's
called mitta which i believe in german
uh german is middle uh in english uh and
you know you can tell they did a good
job with it because you know how hard
this is that's just that is not easy but
mitta nailed that
um so uh that'll be a good place to
learn about stuff like that also
we're next to kreuzberg uh and i'm
pretty sure that uh
as google um kroysberg means cross
browser
so uh that'll be that i think that'll be
instructive for us uh and it's you know
it's beautiful our town you got the
fanstrom the
tv tower you know we got the brandenburg
gate uh right here
uh you know you got the berlin wall um
this is uh i guess paul summer platz
there's not much of the berlin wall left
as you know
uh i made a very you know kind of glib
joke last year you know it was like the
border border collapse
i've since studied a little bit more up
and it turns out it was more of a cursor
east-west resize um but
there's a lot of history there and you
can actually see i guess the remaining
parts of it
if you guys are you know going back town
uh right here at uh
check box charlie um which i'm sure
you're familiar with
i'm sure uh so another great reason to
be here you guys i'm sure do front end
work
you know you probably have designed at
some point an app like this and you had
this
giant hamburger button in your menu bar
well it turns out they have a giant
hamburger street
and i'm sure you guys deal with like max
with and max height
and stuff well guess what they have a
max beer street
uh a lot of history in that kind of
department here uh
i'm sure you guys have uh for i mean you
deal with tags all day
uh i'm sure you know that invented right
here in berlin was the uh
the reichstag
embedded in which you'll find the the uh
of course the the bundestag
um anyway enough about that um
so we have a pr this is actually like a
really really solid lineup that i'm
really excited about
uh and so just want to give you an
overview of how this is going to work
uh it's pretty easy so uh this is
obviously available on the website and
it's responsive check it on your phone
uh and then the idea is that we'll have
breaks uh in between so basically two
talks and a break more or less
um in the during the breaks one thing to
ask
is uh there's actually a beverage
there's a there's a fridge over there
and a fridge over there
if you could actually only use those uh
during the break um so that
uh you know it's not loud for folks
speaking um but otherwise that's how
that's gonna work
um so we have coffee break lunch uh
coffee break
then a longer coffee break with snacks
uh and then you know closing remarks in
the party
uh if you guys know about the wi-fi i
don't know if you guys heard about the
wi-fi
um there's the uh the css id
and the password uh also i've been asked
if you guys want to know about the bifi
that is a german sausage snack totally
just completely unrelated
another cool thing about this conference
is that its hashtag is also a valid css
selector
so if you want to use the hashtag please
go ahead and use that if you want to
mention
css comfy on the internets um another
thing i
need to let you know is actually we're
going to be taking a mood video i guess
which is kind of just a capture of the
mood
so we're actually going to be filming
and by german law i think we actually
have to tell you
uh that that you may be filmed so just
so you know there's gonna be people
cameras
super chills two-man crew and you might
see them around uh also other german
laws
that at least i know about i think we
have to tell you that we might serve
cookies
i don't know what that's about but
apparently we need to tell you that uh
also in terms of other esoteric german
laws if you guys are going to make any
beer here just please
follow the line heistgebot because we
don't want to get into any trouble
but otherwise that's it uh the whole
point is to have fun and learn about css
uh and to uh and and to just enjoy each
other's company so i think we should do
this and so
let's kick it off this is gonna be a
very our first talk is gonna be a lot of
fun
uh and so when i get matthias bannon's
if i'm
pronouncing that correctly uh he's in
from belgium i met this guy when i was
doing
140 bytes javascript code golfing and
this guy was like a total cold golf
wizard and it turns out it's not just
javascript it's css
he knows a ton about all of these deep
and dark corners
uh of a front and web development so
he's going to share a few of them with
us i think 3.14 of them so please help
me welcome
matthias banens
you